oh good  you hungry i could eat yeah man  um what you want uh pizza  chinese kill that noise man  i got a ratatouille  oh [ __ ] that's a wrap dude all right  that's a rather two yo  they rather to it go make my man a  sandwich  yes show them what you got  [Music]  what the [ __ ] son you got a rat up in  your house  what this mean  i don't know what to say man i got a  ratatouille man he a chef just like in  all that movies man  no no hey there's only there's only one  movie  levi all right and he's not a  ratatouille he's a rat  and his name is remy potato potato  potato  i gots myself some ratatouille that's  all i know  order up damn come on levi  voila levi look at this thing man you  see it got bite marks all over it  any good chef has to taste his creation  that's  rat [ __ ] on the sandwich  he didn't make a sandwich though oh hell  no i'm out  my dude you need help  [Music]  oh well ratatouille another negative  review  maybe you wanted charlotte's web